je m'appelle et me dit aujourd'hui je
m'appelle emilie jolie je voudrais
partir avec vous tout au bout du ciel
sur roseix et je voudrais vivre avec
vous ma vie tu t'appelles
joli tu t'appelles emilie jolie
tu voudrais partir avec nous tout au
bout du ciel sur noël et tu voudrais
vivre avec nous
[Musique]
avi
oui c'est ça m'a dit
paris
dites moi oui
mais il ya tant de choses à voir avant
de parti ruth firmament
ya tant de jours des temps de nuit
tu es au début que ta vie
[Musique]
quick
maîtrisant sa chance
ok
[Musique]
lee song et ses chansons c'est ainsi
qu'est qui dit qu'elle voulait quelqu'un
c'est ta propre cabane passe non pas
parce qu'il y fait pas mais parce qu'il
put s est enquis du québec on caresse la
peau ce qui n'était pas vraiment ce qui
piquait aux critiques auxquelles est
triste sa chanson
mais l'a fait dans ce livre qui me
donnera l'envié qu'elle est la petite
fille aux yeux bleus qui va me rendre
quelle est la fréquence libre
tu donneras l'embêter quelle est la
musique et aux yeux bleus qui va le
rendre
moi
je me vois moi dans celui de la voir
je ne vois qu'une fois
ya que toi
à cela
madame
à
[Musique]
ben non
m
lutry cette chanson
[Musique]
qu'il est plus triste le nez hérisson
est la caresser la joue solo
mais non le hérisson réponse bravo